right right right
i'm curious um how hot like
you you the obvious like i think when
people see you guys
the immediate comparison you guys have
gotten is outcast this whole
like since you guys have come out right
um
i think sonically there's some fair
points to that but i also feel like you
know
i feel like you guys are influenced by
so much more than cast
i think it was dope because i remember
go ahead don't say yeah
of course i mean of course man i went to
stink on you that
outcast is my favorite group ever
andre's like my top three ever like when
i went to stankonia
and i was i was like i was
but if my 12 year old self would have
seen me an outcast
crazy with all the plaques and then the
artwork of like the naked girls from the
cds
and [ __ ] like it was amazing but like
i'm i know i think i can't do that no
more man you can't even have artwork and
then cd work
i know it's crazy do you remember how
fire their cds
was always fine cd work you see the
artwork used to be crazy
bro i don't think anyone's ever had
better cds than outcasts
they always had the naked girls on
everywhere yeah you can't leave the
atlanta
the a.t aliens one was the best with
them
this thank you one with
album uh musically see a lot of people
don't like this
but i say my favorite album by them is
thank you just because
i like some i like the hits but i also
like some of the experimental stuff
gasoline dreams i love toilet tissue oh
yeah you don't talk about that song
stank stank love yeah i'm beautiful i
like them typewriters yeah
but also i mean i i don't know if that
would be considered the best i don't
think that
stink on you was that you guys just like
everybody would like
is also like equivalent to mine is that
definitely
at least was the first one i ever heard
that was the first one like i ever
really bought
and then i went back and bought the
other ones yeah that was
still honestly on atl my dad bought
atlas i remember when he let me hold it
i was probably
i had to be i mean when when stan going
came out i was in fifth grade so
whatever year it was i was like a super
little kid
i'm 33 how old are you guys 30. i just
started okay so what kind of you know i
remember like as a kid like
when my i had a like a big homie in my
apartment complex who had at aliens
and like when i saw the cd i was like oh
[ __ ] it's a naked girl exactly
i remember stealing my dads and like
just having it in my room or something
like
playing the music you're doing something
real wrong
i don't know what to do i just really
loved wasn't still and then my mom came
and found it she's like what's this
dad cd which it was like
that man yo i